pas croire que les problèmes des jeunes
ont débuté avec aborder la réalité quand
même de jeunes avant mais la pandémie et
notamment des étudiants mais pas que
c'est le système d c'est à dire des
petit bourg étudiants dans des
supermarchés dans des dents des dans le
secteur du serbe
ceux d'hiver et d'armer les haines des
parents des grands parents quand ils
peuvent et puis parfois des dérives télé
les problèmes croissants de prostitution
sur le campus alors évidemment en irak
ça me concerne heureusement une extrême
minorité les jeunes c'est quand même le
signe que le malaise est tout simplement
les les moyens de vivre et les
conditions de vie de l'étudiant était
déjà très près car c'est avant même
cette forme unique évidemment noté qu
aggraver la situation notamment fragile
la situation des jeunes et parfois
traités en dernier dans son camp les
jeunes ne sont pas parfois considéré les
bornes des sortes empêchant tourner en
rond parce que y manifestent parce
qu'ils font des peines par bp ce qui lie
à la normale à l'orage
et c'est vrai qu effectivement temps
dans notre société les jeunes et bien ne
sont plus peut-être la priorité numéro
un regardez simplement sur sur le plan
économique ça fait quand même 20 ou 30
ans et même plus la priorité la nation
l'inflation était plutôt favorable aux
jeunes
et elle n'est pas fortuite ou aux
personnes plus âgées
donc il ya quand même une évolution
n'est plus entre elles ou trois mois
sans accord
[Musique]